- This right here is the L.A. dog.
Also known as the street meat.
- It's not the bacon or the
dog that makes this hot dog,
It's the grilled onions,
the grilled jalapenos,
a baking sheet, and some Sterno flames.
It's disgusting, it's not to code,
but this is (bleep) delicious.
- In L.A. when it's 2 a.m. and you need
to eat the tastiest thing,
in the fastest way possible.
- After you've been
dancing all night long,
usually when you put one
of these in your mouth,
you're really sweaty, out of breath.
- Oh my God, is this mayo on a hot dog?
- They mayo is weird.
- No, it's not.
- You barely get any dog
you're so distracted by the toppings.
- There's so many different things here.
Just like Los Angeles, the
melting pot of the world.
- A Chicago dog has poppy seed bun,
big ol' Vienna sausage,
got your green relish, hot
peppers, tomato, onions.
- Mustard, no ketchup.
Ketchup is a bullshit
condiment, in my opinion.
- Why does this look like that?
- That's relish.
- It's neon.
- Kinda feel like I should
have like one of those
glow stick tongue thing.
- Who goes to a hot dog place and says,
"Let me get a whole slab of pickle on it"?
- (laughing) Yeah, it's
like two or three pickles...
- Because pickles are good.
- You could wrap the hot
dog itself in this pickle.
- Oh yeah, that's a good dog.
- As the fat person here, I will say that
I feel skinny in Chicago
and this might be one of the reasons.
- I never say anything
bad about Chicago people
because it's so sweet that
they think they have a city.
- Oh!
- If you ever ask for ketchup
on a hot dog in Chicago
you will not get served a hot dog.
- What's this?
- It's ketchup before,
it's like after, no,
- It's the same thing.
- It's before.
- Guys, this is a New York hot dog.
- The dirty-water dog.
- It's got mustard, it's
got some sweet onions,
whatever you wanna do to your dog, you do.
- Um, the onions go on the dog.
I don't believe it.
- The smell is the gatekeeper
to what goes in my mouth.
- It's about capitalism and
like, democracy, this thing.
- This is about minimalism.
- It looks like New
York, how beat up it is.
- Little shriveled.
- What doesn't kill you
makes you strong-ah.
- This looks like something you'd find
at the bottom of your purse
at the end of the night.
And if you were drunk
enough, you would eat it.
- New York doesn't need
to sound appealing to L.A.
- L.A. dog for the win.
- L.A. dog.
- The L.A. dog.
- L.A. is the clear winner.
- Chicago.
- Chicago dog.
- Who doesn't like neon things?
- I wanna apologize to my family,
to my uncles, to my grandmothers.
This L.A. dog, it's beats
the Chicago dog for me.
- The L.A. won.
- New York dog all the way.
- The L.A. dog.
- New York hot dog, that's it.
- What?
- That's it.
- Is what?
Is not the winner.
- That's all you need.
That is all you need for New York.
- You know what the best
part about New York?
We don't even talk about you other cities.
We don't even talk about it.
I don't even know where you guys are from.
It doesn't matter to me.
- I wish there was ketchup.
- Are you kidding me?
- It would be so much, there is ketchup.
- There's no ketchup allowed.
I am not gonna let you use this.